hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend very excited about today's
episode i know sometimes it can seem
like i say that when that's just me
filling space or
my reptile brain saying i'm excited for
the show today but i am i am excited for
the show today and i'm always excited to
be with my good pals my buddies my chill
chums
sona obsession hello and uh matthew w
gourley no it's not my yeah who cares
it is
that's the kind of power i have i can
just assign you a middle name your
middle name is wenzel slaus
gorley and sona is not even your real
name sona
i didn't know that for a while and you
were working with me
for like a year or two
when we had to show our id somewhere
forget if we were traveling whatever way
to get our id's out and it says i saw
that it said talleen
and i thought why has she been lying
about her name lying well it's not your
name no but your name you tell her when
your name is i don't know if andy talks
about this but andy goes by his middle
name too
what's his first name andy randall first
name is paul
yes i've been friends with him for
almost 30 years yeah my first name is
wenzel sloss well that i just assumed
okay
when i found out that you carved your
own little fifes
and played them to mute yourself
um i assumed you had a name like wenzel
swaz
or was it wenceslaus
uh
i've been drinking
anyway the point is yeah again i say
that when i yeah i lost my way i was
yeah andy goes by his middle name too i
think it's i think i knew that i think
andy told me that a long time ago during
a commercial break and i think i said
shut up i gotta
get back to interviewing this guest
which i should have listened to it more
but you were at a commercial i know i
think i just was trying to stop the
conversation it was very rude
what's your middle name christopher um
conan why christopher o'brien
it's nice but did your parents name you
after
probably saint christopher i'm guessing
yeah i don't think there was a
christopher in the family it's funny
because everyone else in my family has a
name and a middle name that connects to
something else and then when my parents
got to me i was the third
they completely threw a hail mary they
were like we're calling him conan yeah
what the hell that's nobody's name
uh and then his middle name is going to
be christopher which i don't think i
don't think there's a christopher that
i'm related to in the past so i think
with me they saw the red hair i'm the
only redhead in the family they saw this
bright orange hair and they just thought
ah
screw it let's just yeah and you were in
the middle it's weird that they stopped
like it's not like they ran out of names
it was like
it was like you were bored and they were
like oh it's like they just took a break
yes well i think in a lot of ways they
did when it came to me yeah
i took a break and caring
took a break and you're loving you're
the personification of a smoke break
take five everyone i know
my real name is
conan is gaelic for take five
yeah and then right after me they are
right back to you know names that are in
the family so it's neil it's luke and
then huh third one who wants a third
one conan i guess
what about a middle name christopher i
think is somebody
and then um then right back they're like
yeah kate we're excited again jane woo
justin
so i don't know what happened with me
they got excited again after you it was
kind of like yeah some girls started
showing fix what we did you're just
intermission
i think soda has been right let's fix
what we did
we can't end on this when you give birth
to the devil
you
that's the part of rosemary's baby they
don't talk about is rosemary had a bunch
of kids afterwards to kind of make up
and they're really good kids for the
devil baby
yeah a bunch of really good kids they
they worked for the peace corps
and they did a lot of they're just great
they're really nice graphic designers
uh they help out a lot in the
neighborhood
they don't talk about their devil
siblings no god no every now and then
they're just great and everyone's having
a wonderful time with that family and
then every now and then
oh god here it comes who's that my it's
our oldest brother
would anyone like to sign
a contract
with this flaming pen
made of lava
um we're cool we were just gonna go
to uh
boston market and get awesome
get some turkey sandwiches i would like
to join you
well if it's cool we'd like to leave you
behind i was the firstborn of beelzebub
yeah
anyway we're gonna get some turkey
sandwiches
if you could get me the coleslaw they
make
that stuff is killer yeah yeah sure
we'll pick up coleslaw i appreciate it
turns out he's very polite
too let me chip in no it's just coleslaw
no i insist
[Music]
no no seriously we got it i think i'd
like to buy for the group you know
you're actually pretty nice well
that's how i get you
that's how i get you i lure you in
remember you'll know the devil
because he'll be the one that offers to
pay for the group at boston market
really
that's how you'll know the devil oh just
me
i got this for the group and get some
sodas while you're at it it's on me
wow devil oldest devil brother from
rosemary baby you you're just nicer than
i thought you'd be well there are
misconceptions about me
anyway
my guest today oh wait you have a
podcast
yes of course
everyone has a podcast now so why not
the son of the devil
but first a word about fracture no
fracture oh no i get a picture on
paper when you can get it on glass
fracture prints
i bet they're not even in business
anymore oh they're not trust me
once the devil starts advertising for
you
your company goes in the [ __ ] real
fast
i get paid by burger king not to mention
them